[Music]
my dad grew up in a small town in
eastern india named hazaribag
where life revolved around coal
schools bridges hospitals libraries were
built over generations directly by the
coal industry
coal companies even provided rides to
movie theaters
my grandfather worked here for 30 years
as a coal mining engineer
when it was time for my dad to decide on
his career
there were now two options in front of
him
coal
and now oil
he picked the latter partly because
their offices had air conditioning
if you've ever been to india over the
summer you may understand that choice
as a result of that simple decision
my family's life transformed
we moved from india to china to texas
all the while i was privileged enough to
receive an elite education
but despite that when it was time for me
to decide on my career
i also felt drawn towards energy issues
how predictable and boring
i wondered if i should distance myself
away from energy just to avoid doing
what two generations in my family had
already done
ultimately i settled on clean energy
telling myself this is different enough
from what my parents did and maybe i can
still retain some semblance of
originality
and i enjoyed it too
for the first time in my career it felt
as as though i was connected
to a mission that was broader than
myself
but deep down something still didn't
feel quite right
as clean energy transition and
sustainability became mainstream
buzzwords
it seemed as though everyone on my
linkedin feed including myself
had suddenly taken up arms in some sort
of war of biblical proportions
there was an epic battle being waged
against climate change and every
investment banker with a green bond was
a climate justice warrior
now i'm all for enthusiasm but it
started to feel a little too convenient
a little inauthentic
and frankly a little hollow
personally i felt ungrounded
the more i tethered myself to this grand
ambition of climate change the more
distant i felt
from my roots and family history
but as i was working to reconcile this
personal dilemma
i came across a broader and much more
important problem
amidst all the excitement about new
clean energy technologies and
innovations what was often never talked
about were the people actually on the
ground
i wondered as the world moved away from
fossil fuels
what would happen to communities like my
dad's hometown who depended on coal for
everything
who is looking out for them
let's take a moment to consider the life
of an average coal mine worker in a
developing economy
they have worked in the mines for 20
years
they've developed hearing impairments
from being too close to blast sites
they have respiratory illnesses from
direct exposure to coal ash day in and
day out
but despite these extreme challenges
this job is a blessing
it is virtually the only thing that
separates his family from extreme
poverty
now imagine what happens
when nearby coal plants in the
surrounding area are shut
he loses his job there's no other
industry in town
which means that the only two options
are to leave town
or try his hand as a daily wage laborer
how tragic
that the same person who bore the brunt
of all the environmental harms of coal
will now also bear the brunt of the
transition to clean energy
as countries move away from fossil fuels
millions in already vulnerable
communities will be put at serious risk
over 10 million people are dependent on
coal just in india but this is a problem
for the world
china indonesia australia west virginia
all of these places have communities
that are dependent
but let me be clear
coal does need to go
if the world has to come close to
meeting our climate change objectives we
do need to phase out fossil fuels over
the next few decades but the way in
which we manage this transition
could be the difference between
sustainable growth
and human catastrophe
now there are some who say that all
transitions have winners and losers it's
been this way forever
that might be true
but the sheer magnitude of the current
energy transition
will be disruptive like nothing we have
ever seen
and when lives are disrupted especially
in developing economies the result is
not just unemployment
it's extreme poverty
now i've also heard the argument
that there will be new clean energy jobs
to make up for the jobs that are lost in
fossil fuels and maybe even more net
more jobs will be created in the
aggregate over the long term
but human beings don't live in the
aggregate or over the long term
they live in the here and now with all
the struggles and dependencies that have
been deepened over generations
some also say that it should be the
government's responsibility to take care
of those who are left behind so that the
private sector can focus on innovation
and technology
but that's simply too convenient just
relying on the government to take care
of social consequences is not a strategy
it's a feel-good exercise
we need to move beyond wishful thinking
and think holistically about how our
energy transition can not just be clean
but also just
now no two communities will have the
same solution
for some it could be a direct swap of
fossil jobs to clean energy jobs
for many others like my dad's hometown
entirely new industries have to be
created whether it's eco tourism
agriculture or construction
but here's the deal
investing in the communities that will
be left behind is not just ethical
it's practical
these same communities represent much of
the opposition to clean energy
legislation today
so investing in investing in them
supporting them and making sure they're
not left behind actually maximizes our
chances of achieving the transition in
the first place
now there's a lot of work that's left to
be done
but there are some important early signs
of progress for example the just
transition initiative and the climate
justice alliance works with companies
all around the world
to pursue climate change mitigation but
also support marginalized communities
all the way from south africa to india
but if you want to make a real dent in
the problem
our efforts have to be bolder and
broader
this is about a lot more than just coal
or any other energy source this is about
about how we think of sustainability in
the first place
sustainability must be broader than just
protecting the environment it must
include protecting people
especially those who are most at risk
now companies and governments are
certainly important but i believe that
you and i have the most important role
to play
we know that millennials and gen zers
are the most likely to make purchasing
decisions based on sustainable business
practices
so your pocketbook
can actually be a vote
an expression of solidarity with the
voices who are not yet at the table
and as future business leaders
it's our opportunity and responsibility
to ensure that those same voices also
belong in the board room
so the next time you're stepping out for
your morning coffee or deciding what
stocks to back on robin hood or
preparing for the next meeting in the
board room
push yourself
to take that extra step
challenge yourself to do a little extra
research
ask yourself
how can i support a world that is not
just more clean
but more just
as we scramble to reduce our carbon
footprint
what can i do for those who will be left
behind
thank you
[Music]